in december of in a few months ago
december 2021 diana pasulka said on
calling all beings that it's a podcast
which i'll leave a link to that in the
description that you wanted to create a
drug that interfaces with the phenomenon
on our terms
what was she referring to um i think she
was referring to some comments i had
made about
you know my frustration
listening to experiencers
uh and actually having some experiences
in in my immediate family
um
who
had no control over
the events that were occurring to them
um
and you know there's many many many
examples of this in the literature uh
and i i
if you imagine that whatever this
is
has to
communicate with humans through
somehow our sensory apparatus in our
brain
whether it's
you know directly
if it's sound based well then there's no
drug for that but if it's somehow coming
inside through
the sensory apparatus i used the term
telefactoring
before
um
that
uh
if it's interfering with us in some way
why couldn't we make if we understand
enough about how the interference is
being generated
maybe there's a drug to stop us
or to prevent that from occurring you'd
i mean there's a lot of science that
have to be done around something like
that and i'm not saying
it's doable tomorrow or
anything like that
uh but
um
the the notion is for the people who
feel that they
are
being uh inappropriately
interacted with give them the ability to
turn it off you know it makes you wonder
sometimes again it's pure speculation
makes you wonder sometimes whether
people who are in mental health
facilities
today
so-called schizophrenics or what have
you um who
can't seem to function properly in
normal society
how many of them have such
again
speculation
have these continued interactions they
just can't turn them off
it would drive you crazy if some if you
constantly heard something in your head
i i just bought a t-shirt by the way
that's really fun i found it online it
said the voices are back
excellent